it feels like it belongs to someone else
[Music]
that shield represents a lot of things
to a lot of people
symbols are nothing without the women
and men that give them meaning
we need someone to inspire us again
the world's more complicated now
i'm never gonna stop
this world is us
there's no going back
it doesn't have to be a war it already
is
we can't lose this fight
if we do this
we're gonna do it our own way
so we're partners co-workers not
necessarily a team
no
we look damn good though
all right here we go i like it ready
yeah
wait for it action
it's an example of opposites of track we
couldn't be more different
i got a vibranium off and i can fly
there are definitely days where i feel
like he's gonna kill me
what's going on in that cyborg brain of
yours gear's turning oh they're
malfunctioning
they're on fire god i hate him he's like
you know when you have a fly in your
house and it just won't go away
but we have a very good dynamic uh
absolutely not
come on i'm telling you we got we have
fun with each other and that carries
into
these characters so what's our plan
so no plan great
i'm so excited because it's exhilarating
it's the throwbacks all those bloody
comedy action movies you just don't know
if they're gonna kill each other or not
hello girl kick your eyes
you